hello subscribers Watchers and people
who are apparently bored on the Internet
okay so the other day someone commented
on one of my videos asking me to reduce
my foul language but I was like I don't
cuss that much I mean maybe I say the
word [ __ ] a lot such a fun word but for
anyone who has a problem with my foul
language take heart in knowing that I'm
just as crass off-camera as I am on
because you just got to be yourself than
providing entertainment and secondly I
really wanted to thank all of my 5,000
plus subscribers for their support there
are many more informative videos to come
topped with many more shits [ __ ] and
damn its again not that I cuss that much
I mean I really don't you know here and
there maybe but I mean right otherwise
known as complete and utter [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dammit [ __ ]
[ __ ] below this [ __ ] dick [ __ ] [ __ ]
up the end of the world is [ __ ]
money shot the dog [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
douchebags producer dancing [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
all tickly this [ __ ] piss [ __ ] like this
Imam because each bags [ __ ] [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] bad ass balls
that shit'll blow [ __ ] nuts [ __ ]
blows damn pissed [ __ ] douchebags
bout us to signal that ass faster douche
claiming that dicks have shipping summon
some kids
shitstorm dudes nuts holy [ __ ] close
corporate douchebags [ __ ] shitty shitty
numbers box box box douches [ __ ] all
sack you should [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I bought that [ __ ] douche bag
piss off loes [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
skip this [ __ ] sweet ass outta [ __ ] flip
that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whack it
[ __ ]
shitty execution pissed off do [ __ ]
shitty ball [ __ ] batshit crazy
badass [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that ass
[ __ ] badass vibrator because it's badass
some [ __ ]
[ __ ] shitty you suck ass calm
[ __ ] teabag balls a little dumb ass
[ __ ] fluffy baby dick douche bag come
back [ __ ] you in a second [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
dumb ass [ __ ] eating smart a porn
[ __ ] that ass like [ __ ] Oh
badassness [ __ ] badassness not asking
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like an ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] douche talking
Lexington seal his dick dick douche bag
piss [ __ ] that blows oh [ __ ] I don't do
it to be his dick like you give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but if anyone asks
you have press [ __ ] [ __ ]
definitely because I'm a dick dousche
eat pissed off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] get your
head out of your ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I'm Jeremy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ball man [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] thanks again for your
support not that one the other one